this week there were more signs that the
u.s economy is roaring back to life and
they come as president biden
is proposing trillions of dollars in new
government spending
for more on the economy and the
president's latest plan we are joined by
cbs news senior business analyst jill
schlesinger
jill good morning and let's start with
the latest it's the third
big near two trillion dollar spending
plan that the president has proposed
what were your key takeaways and what
are some of the details you can share
with us
well i think what's interesting is that
the biden plans taken together they're
like the trilogy
right we had the american jobs plan the
american rescue plan
and now we have the american families
plan and the major theme
of all of them is a central one that's
really different
it is that government is important in
helping american families
and the american economy and i think
what's really important about this that
that we look as we look at this these
three plans together
they really are relying on corporations
and wealthy americans to foot the bill
to make this big
change in the uh role of government
jill tell us more about that because we
know that the
republican opposition to this is that
it's too expensive and that these
projects are you know
all part of a democratic wish list but
is the bottom line that this
administration wants to
close loopholes and tax the rich
well i think that there's a combination
of factors here you know you look at
this
recent 1.8 trillion dollars it's a
trillion dollars of spending over
10 years it's 800 billion dollars of
making tax credits permanent
and the way that this is happening is
primarily
by raising taxes for the wealthiest
americans
the administration says it's for the top
one percent and the four aspects of that
plan
would be to actually raise the top rate
to 39.6 percent that's where it was
before the trump tax cuts of 2017
it's raising the top capital gains tax
rates
for those people who make more than a
million dollars it's
changing the way estate taxes are levied
on people who pass assets down through a
generation
and it's the fourth poll is really
interesting it's injecting 80 billion
dollars into the irs
to help the irs conduct audits of these
high earners
again this is very much focused on high
earners
and the previous plan was focused on the
corporations so
put that together that's a lot of taxing
for the wealthiest as well as
corporations to foot the bill of this
real shift away from no government into
more government joe we talk about
coronavirus
recovery health-wise so more than 100
million americans vaccinated now we just
mentioned
when it comes to financial recovery from
the coronavirus where are we
right now i think that it's
really good news this week we found out
that in the first quarter of this year
the economy expanded at a 6.4 percent
annualized rate that is huge it is
really a an improvement where we were
just think about it over a year ago
where the economy was contracting
so dramatically and when you look at
this economic performance in the first
quarter it's
likely to continue economists tell me
that the u.s could actually expand at a
six to seven percent growth rate for the
entire year
that would be the quickest expansion
since the mid-1980s so we are well
on our way to recovery of course we need
to get more people back to work
but man this turnaround is unexpected
when you look back just a year ago okay
jill schlesinger
as always thanks very much